I was either stranded in here Allah with
this likely predator or stranded out
there in the middle of a walk down hello
and welcome to all daint a creepypasta
horror stories cooked to perfection with
a splash of red sauce
my name is cz and I will be your server
in this episode morning classes with
horrible teachers are hard enough to get
through without an insane clown on the
loose in the school
today's story takes us through the worst
day of school let's dig right in
I heard he has a thing going on with
that girl Gina Wendel then she half
whispered we were sitting in the back of
second period science as my best friend
Lexi spilled the tea on the latest
rumors about mr. Markum the history
teacher / volleyball coach who's been
the subject of some pretty messed up
rumors as of late
Leslie Franklin was supposedly upstairs
getting something from her locker after
practice one night and saw Gina coming
out from a private tutoring session with
mr. Marcum oh why the how would you even
want to where she must really need an A
in US history that's so gross you will
know he's old from what I heard she
wouldn't be the first what she was
telling me was sadly probably true the
rumors about mr. Marcum had swirled into
a frenzy since the winter break incident
when he had supposedly given Kim
Ichikawa a ride home after the last
volleyball practice while her parents
were gone
the bell rang do you think it's true
though Lexi asked me as I dropped off my
science textbook in my locker exchanging
it for my US history book I don't know
why don't you ask him I told her
mockingly we both had mr. Markum next
period together I bet you could find out
at Mauna I think he likes you there were
no and once again boo he does call on
you a lot like a lot a lot nope don't
care
darn it not again the locker had snagged
a bit at the skirt I was wearing and it
was pinched inside my locker door come
on we're gonna be late you could be like
a school hero exposed him for what he
really is and I'm fired we were sitting
in mr. Markham's class now and I didn't
want to have this discussion with him in
the room
she was right though of the four
students he had randomly called on this
lesson three of them were me Lexi can we
please have this discussion some other
ivana
you're not talking during my lecture now
are you my heart skipped a beat had he
overheard us talking about him if you
have something to say about District
Columbia vs. Heller
why don't you just share it with the
class no I don't sir he paused and
stared at me a moment before continuing
his lesson really in front of the whole
class he must really be getting cocky
thanks a lot I muttered to Lexi Ivana
see me after the bell the whole class
booed at this and I rolled my eyes
great the last thing I wanted was to be
one-on-one with the biggest creep
teacher in the school
when class let out Lexi told me she'd
wait for me in the hall mr. Markum
waited for the whole class to empty out
then close the door I remained at my
desk he didn't say anything at first he
took his time walking over and sitting
on the desk directly in front of me he
stared at me for a moment the side as if
he were still contemplating whether or
not he was going to punish me the
silence was uncomfortable then he went
into his rant about how he was
supposedly concerned with my performance
lately how it was reflected by behavior
in class it was all bull he wouldn't
shut up though
he was going to make me late for my next
class at this point I saw Lexi waiting
outside the door
I wanted to signal her to just go on
without me but her back was turned this
is exactly the kind of thing I'm talking
about are you even paying attention I
just he interrupted me he started asking
me all these questions is there
something going on with my life is there
something wrong at home the passing
period ended but he told me he'd write
me a pass to my next class then things
started getting really weird he started
asking personal questions if there's
something else distracting me if I had a
boyfriend I needed to get out of here I
made up some story about being
overwhelmed by my schoolwork I don't
know why I thought that would get him to
let me go but I think it had the
opposite effect
so I froze for a moment then stood up
out of my chair he gets to his feet as
well with a scary look in his eyes
before it could escalate any further an
announcement comes over the intercom
it took probably about 15 seconds for
the reality of the situation to sink in
I was either stranded in here alone with
this likely predator or stranded out
there alone in the middle mr. Markum
told me to get against the wall near the
door as he turned off the lights he came
and sat right next to me on the fuller
uncomfortably so my head was spinning
out of control that's when I realized
the door nobody had locked the door I
looked to the door and realized there
was someone standing right on the other
side of it not daring to budge or make a
sound I tried to conceal my breathing
taking slow deep breaths
the footsteps stopped in front of the
door I was shaking but the room was
quiet whoever was standing out there had
tried to get in the door was already
locked I didn't know if I should be
relieved to be safe or outraged that mr.
Markham hadn't locked me into our
conversation after class
the intruder continued to stand outside
the door then suddenly the entire room
seemed to shake as the guy threw his
body against the door he tried this a
second time before the side of a girl
screaming could be heard from down the
hall
what happened next took the horrors I
had experienced up to that point and
twisted them into something ten times
more terrifying the guy on the other
side of the door started blowing this
clown horn over and over the sound
drifted away from our door and toward
the screaming girl who continued to
shriek and call for help
I looked to mr. Markham as if to suggest
he should go out there and try to help
this girl he avoided my eye contact
freaking coward all at once the
screaming and the clown horn stopped at
the sound of a thud I gasped because the
severity of the situation had hit me
this wasn't just another drill this is
the real thing what schools all across
the country practice lockdowns for was
this this person this intruder with the
clown horn wasn't just pulling some kind
of joke he was dangerous my mind went to
a dark place a worst possible
Aereo and it hit me hard my eyes started
to blur with tears I buried my head in
my hands just trying to focus on taking
deep breaths then I felt a cold pair of
hands on my shoulders and they started
to caress me that mother pig he was
using this horrible situation to his
advantage he was trying to take
advantage of me at my most vulnerable
moment and maybe the worst part was that
I was trapped I couldn't even make a
sound without putting my own life in
danger at this point I didn't care
anymore I didn't care about the lockdown
the intruder any of it I needed to get
out of this room no I pulled away from
his grip and ran to the door leaving him
alarmed but he wasn't quick enough to
stop me
I unlocked it and slipped out into the
empty hallway I didn't really have much
of a plan other than to hide I looked
left further down the hall a girl was
lying unconscious on the floor with a
guy in a black-and-white clown suit
standing over her he didn't seem to have
noticed me I looked to the right an
empty hallway rows of lockers and one
trash can I didn't know if this would
work but I didn't really have another
option I quietly ran to my right jumped
and landed in the trash can trying to
make as little noise as possible lucky
for me the can was mostly empty so I was
able to crouch down and not be seen
poking at the top it was quiet for a
moment then the clown horn started
repeatedly honking again
it was gradually getting louder which
meant the clown was headed in my
direction my hiding spot was about to be
tested
[Music]
the clown ganked the rim of the garbage
can and said it's humbling out onto the
floor a pair of big shiny obsidian black
eyes were staring down as the clown
stood over me with a disgusting grandma
it was the face of an old-style circus
clown he must have been wearing blackout
contacts or something his face was
completely greased down in white makeup
except for his lips and the dots on his
cheeks both of which were painted black
in fact his entire outfit was black and
white making him look like he had
stepped out of a black-and-white
photograph and into reality the only
part that did look more cartoonish was
how very bloodthirsty his grin was I was
lying on my back on the floor where I
had been dumped out of the garbage
Candice this horrifying thing reached
down for me I only knew of one thing
left to do as hard as I could I kicked
my foot up into his balls but to my
shock and horror this attack did nothing
to him the clown didn't even flinch it
seemed to cause him no pain whatsoever
I felt his silk gloves close around my
neck as he hugged me to the ground I
tried to scream but I felt my throat
closed up and they knew it would do me
no get anywhere all I could do was look
up at this circus draw in a nightmare
and and there was something else just
above my head with someone's overstaffed
Locker it wasn't fully closed the bottom
of the door was pushed open by some
object that didn't quite fit inside but
it looked like the owner had tried to
cram it shut anyhow I reached for the
locker door and he hanged out it it gave
a little bit but it was stuck I was
starting to black out
if I could just point free I gave it a
hard tug and pulled on it my vision was
fading almost entirely black know I
maybe only realized it it worked when I
heard the familiar sound of the Locker
flying open and it crashed against the
clown's head knocking it backwards and
off of me an unbelievable amount of junk
came pouring out whatever was in there
must have been heavy because it had
really knocked the clown hard in the
head which was good because I also
needed a moment to come to I had one
more idea if this didn't work I was done
for as fast as I could I took all the
junk out of the locker and hold it at
the clown textbooks an instrument case a
pair of shoes anything I could find the
clown seemed woozy and it got back to
its feet and regained its bearings just
as I threw my last piece of ammo it
seemed like none of the junk in that
lock I was big enough to hurt the clown
which didn't seem to even feel or notice
anything other than the blow to its head
but hurting it wasn't my plan I had
completely emptied out the locker this
was it do or die I stepped back into the
locker as the clown with a twisted face
of anger and frustration charged at me
as I pulled the door shut as much as
possible without pinching my hand
[Music]
everything went black as I shut myself
into the locker and the Furious clown
slammed into the door effectively
locking me in there was no scream or
roar of frustration
just the echoey reverberation of the
clown crashing up against the metal door
he fumbled with the handle
shortly before realizing that it was no
good then I heard something move in the
distance and the clown started beeping
its horn once again and heading up to
some other part of the school I stayed
safe in that locker for hours until the
school was cleared and the principal
used his master key to let me out the
light hurt my eyes as I collapsed onto
the hallway floor I had been limited to
the tiny amount of light that poured in
through three thin slots on the locker
door the principal gave me a little nod
and told me good thinking or something
along those lines before turning and
attending to the more important matters
at hand the hallway was now filled with
police officers school administrators
news reporters photographers and wait
what were Lexi's parents doing here my
best friend's dad was standing maybe 15
feet down the hall with his arm around
her mom who was sobbing and dabbing at
her eyes as the commotion flowed around
them like a rock cutting through a
stream what what had happened he looked
around some more and realized they
weren't the only ones it looked like
there were a few more sets of parents
and tears scattered around the hallway
here and there there were no other
students around I guess the rest of the
day's classes had cancelled before I got
up from off the floor where I had fallen
out of the locker I noticed a little
ripped piece of fabric fall on the
ground right where I fell it looked like
it had been a piece of the clown's neck
ruffle that I've been caught in the
closing locker door and probably ripped
off when it tried to escape there was
text on it it said it's C and Parks the
rest was torn off and I couldn't read it
a bright flash fill the room reporters
were taking pictures of mr. Marcum but
to my surprise he wasn't being
handcuffed or interrogated by angry
parents a news anchor wearing a tie
holding a microphone started to praise
him going on about this one brave
teacher whose heroics may have saved the
lives of countless students then he
started going into this phony story
about how he immediately ran out to
fight off the clown and protect the
students the moment the lockdown was
called Yeah right you've gotta be
kidding me
I was too drained to care though I was
crammed into a locker with no food and
not a big slot for air and I really felt
like I was going to black out again I
took a seat back down on the floor and
closed my eyes for a minute mr. Marcum
finished up his interview and the
reporter wrapped up the story this is
the second climate act our nation has
seen this week after two students at a
school and garden post just yesterday
were fortunately unharmed during the
lockdown incident for czn news 23 I'm
poppy Harlow I looked around at the
devastation surrounding me the incident
was obviously over but I still felt this
huge pit in my stomach as if nothing had
been resolved to clown attacks in one
week
sure the other school was probably
nowhere near here but still all the
reporters and police officers seemed to
just be going about their business as if
this were just a part of their routine
or something where was the urgency why
wasn't anyone doing anything about this
for a moment I got really angry but then
the anger was just replaced with pain my
heart slowly broke as I sat there i
couldn't get Lexi's mom's face out of my
head what I ever see Lexi again what
school ever be the same I'm pretty sure
I knew the answer to both questions
when my parents arrived to pick me up
both of their eyes were swollen and
thread
thanks for listening to all Danes a
creepypasta your total comes out to $23
but if you like this video right now
I'll waive that fee and give you
everything you just listen to absolutely
free
big thanks to spirit voices for
narrating this episode definitely go
check out her channel other guest
narrators include penny tails up Andrew
stick bee I highly recommend you check
out their channels click the playlist on
the left to check out every other creepy
clown school lockdown incident and
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive